neutrinos a type of elementary particles
in fact they're the most common type of
matter particle but they don't interact
very much with the environment that
means they're hard to pin down
so as we're sitting here trillions of
these particles of zipping through our
bodies and there's nothing we can do
about it and there's a small chance
maybe 25% chance that over the course of
a person's lifetime there'd be one
direction of one neutrino with an atom
in your body luckily these particles
don't cause any harm and and they don't
leave any trace as they pass through our
bodies right through the earth and vast
distances across the universe so they
really are ghostly elusive bits of
matter that are produced often when
nuclear reactions happen for example in
the core of the Sun or in a nuclear
reactor on earth as well as when a
massive star explodes at the end of its
lifetime as a gigantic supernova
explosion back in 1987 this massive star
exploded at the end of its life in a
satellite galaxy of the Milky Way and
when that happened astronomers starting
with a couple of observers based in
Chile happened to notice this star
suddenly brightened pretty much
overnight and they realized that
something was going on and and indeed it
continued to brighten and and we
recognized it was quickly recognized as
a supernova explosion the nearest one
that we know about in some 400 years
pretty much since the invention of the
telescope so that made it a big deal and
yet it was not quite in our galaxy and
our neutrino detectors
back in 1987 were just sensitive enough
that three different neutrino detectors
around the world registered a total of a
couple of dozen particles so just two
dozen events that were recorded two
dozen neutrinos coming from this massive
explosion really allowed us for the
first time to confirm the physics of
what happens when a star explodes at the
end of its life because these particles
don't
interact with much they can escape from
the sight of mayhem basically from the
core of the explosion unhindered and
reach us and therefore confirm directly
what's going on so that the energies of
the neutrinos that were detected for
example were were consistent with the
predictions that astrophysicists had
furnished for supernova explosions so
that allowed them to sort of confirm
some basic overall facts about what a
supernova explosion entails now when a
massive star explodes at the end of its
life it could either collapse into a
black hole collapse all the way into a
black hole or it could halt at what we
call a neutron star a ball of neutrons
and that's it that's the end product and
if the neutrino flux fades away slowly
that suggests that it turned into a
neutron star whereas if it cuts off very
sharply that would tell us that this
star collapsed all the way into a black
hole
now neutrino physicists are ready and
waiting hoping that one of these days a
supernova would explode somewhere in our
galaxy the Milky Way even if it's on the
far side of the Milky Way and we might
not see it because the dust the
interstellar dust obscures the visible
light the neutrinos would still get
through so the neutrino detectors would
observe that a supernova has occurred
even if our optical telescopes talk
you